foreign
of computer vision the ability to
accurately track objects within image
and videos has become a crucial task
with numerous applications from
surveillance systems to autonomous
vehicles object tracking place a pivotal
role in understanding and analyzing
visual data and when it comes to
tackling this challenge in Python one
powerful tool stands out is opencv
opencv short for open source computer
vision library is a popular and widely
used open source library that provides a
plethora of functions and algorithms for
image and video processing with its
comprehensive set of tools opencv offers
an extensive range of capabilities for
object tracking making it a go to choice
for researchers developers and Hobbits
alike the process of object tracking
involves locating and following a
specific object as it moves throughout a
sequence of frames in a video or images
opencv leverages a variety of techniques
to accomplish this task including motion
analysis feature extraction and machine
learning based approaches these
techniques enable the system to detect
and track objects based on their
appearance motion or even both in this
tutorial we will delve into the
fascinating world of object tracking
using opencv in Python we will explore
various methodologies and algorithms and
if you love to watch these types of
videos please subscribe to our simply
learn YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn
according to recent studies Am Machine
learning related job postings have
increased by 344 percent in the past
five years companies across Globe are
actively seeking professionals who can
harness the power of data and build an
intelligent systems and the average
salary is 150 000 in the US and 15 lakhs
in India become an expert Ai and machine
learning professional with this a and
machine learning bootcamp in
collaboration with Caltech which will
help you advance your career as an anml
specialist this a and machine learning
bootcamp includes live classes delivered
by industry experts answer Labs industry
relevant projects and master classes by
Caltech professors this a and machine
learning bootcamp provides caltex ctms
academic progress to help you accelerate
your data science career
statistics python machine learning deep
learning natural language processing and
supervised learning are all included in
the air and machine learning bootcamp
caltex a and machine learning bootcamp
is ideal for those looking for a
competitive advantage in the age of new
Cutting Edge Technologies the curriculum
provides a thorough grasp of ai-based
Technologies like machine learning NLP
deep learning speech recognization
reinforced learning and other topics
enroll now and analog exciting a and
machine learning opportunities the link
is in the description box below so
without any further Ado let's get
started over to our training expert so
hi there let's start with the
object tracking using opencv python so
in this I have this folder I have just
opened this folder named tracking object
in this I have one folder name at DNN
model on that I have classes dot txt
these are the person bicycle car
motorbike the object you want to track
okay and there is one YOLO V4 CFG what
is
YOLO V4 CFG okay so CFG this model
definition files include Network
definitions hyper parameters and anchor
settings a template of this file can be
found in the darknet OR CFG YOLO
installation directory
okay so this file must match the weights
file
this YOLO V for weights so what is YOLO
V4 weights so like all other models
in the YOLO family the YOLO V4 model is
used for object detection object
detection problems are where you need to
identify where particular objects are in
a given image or video or in webcam
okay
so these files I will put this in uh you
know
so these are the two videos in which we
will detect the object and I will put
these DNN model files in a drive and you
can download the files from the
description box below okay so I will
here
start with the object detection so here
I will
create a new file name
object
detection
okay dot py
okay
so in this I will first import
cd2
okay then
import numpy
as NP
so we are using visual code Studio you
can use your you know favorite personal
ID okay so what is
CV2
so opencv has a function to read video
which is CV2 video capture we can access
our webcam using pass 0 in the function
parameter if you want to capture CCTV
footage then we can pass rtsp URL in the
function parameter which is really
useful for the video analysis
so this opencv developer chose when they
created The Binding generators
okay
so the module import you can import the
module using CV2 only
and this numpy as NP
so NP is nothing we wrote numpy is in
short form and numpy can be used to
perform a wide variety of mathematical
operations on array it adds powerful
data structure to python that guarantee
efficient calculation with arrays and
matrices
and IT Supplies an enormous library of
high level mathematical function that
can operate on these arrays and matrices
okay uh numpy at support for the large
multi-dimensional array and matrices
along with the large collection of high
level mathematical functions
okay
so let's proceed further
so here I will create one
function name as object detection so I
can use it in the tracking file okay so
here I will add class
I will write here
object
detection
so here def is used for the Define of
function
in it
self
weights
path equals to
DNN
slash model
slash YOLO V4 this file
okay this value
see where is the path of the file and
the DNN model folder there is one file
YOLO V4 weights okay dot
weights
comma CFG path
equals to
DNN
model
slash YOLO V4
dot ch
okay
so
here I will like self
Dot
nms
threshold
was to
0.4
then self
dot I will write here confidence
threshold
equals to 0.5
okay then self Dot
image
size equals
so
what is nms threshold
so it is used for the object detection
we can easily process the images as well
as the videos to identify the object
faces
and This Confidential threshold
so it is a set of corresponding
confidences like a box is a set of
bounding boxes you can say
a threshold used to filter Boxes by
confidences in this case
okay and these comes under the YOLO
model
so moving forward let's load the network
yeah
and let's load the network so I will
write here Network
CV2
Dot
DNN Dot
read
net
it is a function of reading the network
or CB2 the weights
path then CFG path
okay
and here we will enable GPU queue. so
for that I will write Network
Dot
set
variable
back end
CV2
dot DNN dot DNN
back end
quota
okay
then
I will write here Network
then dot set
preferable
Target
then CV2 Dot
DNN Dot
then again DNM
Target
okay then Cuda
then this is nothing we are just
enabling the GPU queue okay so here I
will write self dot model
equals to CV2 dot DNN
detection
model
net
okay
so here I will write Network
so moving forward let's set the classes
as a cell so self dot classes
goes to empty array
okay itself
I think
and self Dot
load
class names
indentation error will come
so self
Dot
colors
equals to NP Dot
random
dot uniform
then
0 comma 255 comma the size will be
80 comma 3.
okay this type of project you can use in
your resume or on your project you can
show
case in your University or College
okay then self
dot model Dot
set input
params
then size
equals to
self
dot image size
then self dot image
size
comma scale it to
1 by 255
okay
so
here we will load the class names so for
that
I will write here
DF
load
class names
self
comma
classes
path equals to
where is the class path so again I have
to go in DNN model
then again class
okay so here I will write
DNN
model
slash
classes Dot pxt
okay
then with open
classes
but
do read format
as
as file
object
so for classes class names
in file
object
dot read lines
and we already know what is in the
classes.exe these are the all the
objects files okay 80 objects this is
known as a quality data set you as you
can see
so
read lines
classes class
name
equals to
class name dot strip
then self Dot
classes dot open it will append with the
class name
okay
then here I will write just take care of
these indentations in Python
self dot colors
than equals to NP dot random
Dot uniform
uniform
here I will give 0 comma 255
comma
size
question
80 by 3
okay then return
cell Dot
classes
so here I will add this
detect
then self
comma frame we will trade
then it will return
cell dot model
Dot detect
frame comma nms threshold
threshold
equals to
sell
Dot
nms
threshold
okay then I will write here
cons threshold
confidence threshold
equals to
self Dot
confidence
ratio
okay
so
so let's create one more file of the
tracking
so I will write now name your tracking
dot p y
so in this file what we I will import
CV2 as we discussed we know what is CV2
then numpy
as NP we already know what is number
from
object
detection
port
what was the function name
this let me copy it
and paste it here
okay
okay this
yeah
so import
okay let me rename this
uh the object detection I guess but it
will work later on we can do
and here I will import the math function
so here first we will initialize the
object detection to OD to the shorted
form
the
okay
then I will write cap capture
foreign
capture
equals to CV2
Dot
video capture
then
first we will try in this video or
this video
okay so let's take first this pixels
so I will write here you can take any
type of video
pixels
Dot
MP4
okay then here we will initialize the
count so count equals to zero
and there's Center
points
previous frame
tra
and then tracking
objects
question
okay my bad
and track
ID
equals to zero
then here I will write the small
function while
true
then the rectangle or the frame
equals to capture
capture dot read
okay if you will pass here in this video
capture if you will pass here zero it
will open the webcam of your laptop
or your PC webcam
and here I will write
count
plus equals to 1.
okay
not
then
okay
so
let me add the point for the current
frame
so here I will at the center
points of the current frame
okay
then
here
here we will detect objects on frame for
that I have to write class
IDs
of a scores
boxes
goes to
audited
frame
then for
box
and boxes
X comma y
comma W comma h
right like this
for the better visual then box
okay
so here I will write c x
question
in it
then X
plus
X plus weight
divided by 2 okay x axis plus X is
divided plus weight divided by 2
then
then here I will let C for the Cy
in it
y plus y Plus
height
because
y point will be like this from like this
and axis will be like this that's why we
added the width to the X and the height
to the Y
okay divided by 2.
so Center
points
current
frame
dot app and
to the
c x comma
C1
okay
so here CV2 dot rectangle
to the frame
comma then X comma y
come up
X
Plus
width then y
plus height okay
then
I will add one more
zero comma 255 comma 0
comma 2.
and remember that only at beginning
We compare previous and the current
frame okay only at the beginning if
count
equals to 2
that's for point
in Center
current frame
4 point
in
Center previous string
then distance
equals to
math
dot I plot
I bought
of pt2
minus PT
then pt2
comma PT
1. okay these are the points
so if I will write here if distance
is greater than 20
these are the 20 points so tracking
objects
track
ID Professor PD
okay
I will try to
like
yeah
and the track
ID
plus equals to 1.
or else
tracking
objects then copy
objects Dot
copy
it's a copy function it will you know
drag and copy the particular object
here I will write the center
of points the current frame
copy equals to
Center
parts of the current frame dot copy
okay
that's for objects
ID
comma
in checking
objects
something
copy
dot items
object
s
equals to false
then for
point in Center
okay
when the point will be in Center that
the center points of the current frame
copy
it again
then
here the distance
equals to
math
Dot
High plot
zero
PT 0
then here I will write comma
1.
1 minus
DT one
okay
so here I will update the ID's positions
so for that I will write if this stands
is greater than 20
then
tracking
objects
then
objects ID
equals to PD
it's objects
what's happening
okay then object
object exist
question two
two
and if point in Center
points
current
frame
press enter
points of the current frame dot remove
D okay here then continue if it
means the same
okay and here I will remove the ID which
are the lost so if
not
object axis
then tracking
objects dot pop object ID
okay
and here
I will
add new IDs which are found for that I
have to write for object
ID
dot PT
and
tracking objects dot items
then CV2 Dot
Circle
frame
PT
5.
0 comma zero comma 255
minus one
then CV2 Dot
put
text
then frame
TR
objects ID
and comma
comma
one
minus seven
okay
zero comma one
these are the all the width and the
height values
okay
then here I will write print
the
tracking object
attacking objects
then here I will write
print
the
current frame of the legs left point
current
same
for that I have to write print
Center Point to current frame
CV2 dot I am sure
that
frame
comma frame
okay
and make a copy of the points for that I
have to write Center
points previous frame equals to Center
points current frame dot copy
k equals to CV2 Dot
then what
okay if
k equals equals to 27
okay
so after that I will write cap Dot
please
release
CV2
okay here I have to write capture CB2
dot destroy all windows
okay so the code is complete let's run
this
okay it's running
opensv okay
so
as you can see
in our video
it is tracking the object perfectly by
frame by frame okay slowly and steadily
by frame by frame
c one two three four five six
okay it's a huge video
okay it's 4K video maybe that is why it
is stucking little bit but it is it is
reading on the basis of the frame by
frame okay
let's try the another video
here first I will kill the terminal
then I will change the name to
one two three dot MP4
and I will run it
so as you can see it is tracking in the
right order
okay
see it is tracking perfect see car is
moving but it's tracking and here all
the points we have measured that x axis
y x is all it's coming
okay see it's dragging perfectly
and if you want this full code
you can comment down the below and I
will update all the necessary files and
the libraries in the description box
below you can download from that
so with that said we have come to end of
this video if you have any question or
queries you can comment down below our
team of expert we'll reach out soon as
soon possible
you can check the course from the
description box below regarding AIML and
thank you for staying with us thank you
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here